at the european parliament a strong show
of support for the people of ukraine
this chamber with many parliamentarians
wearing the ukrainian colours was
addressed by video link from kiev by
president zielinski he had one clear
request
we are fighting for our existence for
our survival and this is the main
motivation for us but we are also
fighting to be an equal member of europe
and i think that today we are showing
who we are the european union is with us
with ukraine the european union will be
stronger without ukraine it'll be lonely
we've proved our strength we've proved
that we're at least the same as you
please prove that you're with us please
prove that you're not going to let us go
prove that you're really europeans
there was strong condemnation of
president putin's actions which the eu
considers illegal
and abhorrent it's not only ukraine
that's under attack
international law
rules-based international order
democracy human dignity are also under
attack
this is
geopolitical terrorism pure and simple
the president of the european commission
then spoke about the possibility of
ukraine joining the european union today
the european union and ukraine are
already closer than ever before
there is still a long path ahead
we have to end this war
and we should talk about the next steps
but i am sure
nobody in this hemi cycle can doubt
that a people that stands up so bravely
for our european values
belongs in our european family at the
end of the session the parliament voted
overwhelmingly to call on eu
institutions to work towards granting
ukraine candidate status but the vote is
purely symbolic it's the european
council the 27 member nations who make
the final decision and then there's a
long drawn-out process to qualify to
become a member
the size of the vote
637 out of 676
though an indication of the level of
feeling in support of ukraine here james
bayes al-jazeera at the european
parliament in brussels